deep learning is a subset of machine
learning where it's a
a family of algorithms that
simply do the prediction task of of
inferring from
some principle learning some principle
based on on data
and being able to be deployed and apply
on this a problem and solve this problem
in a production environment based on the
data that they learned
a before welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
in this episode we're going to take ai
and deep learning to the next level
meet jonathan gaifman co-founder and ceo
of desi
the deep learning company building the
next generation of ai
he co-founded desi after completing his
phd in computer science at the technion
israel institute of technology
his research focused on making deep
neural networks dnns
more applicable for mission critical
tasks jonathan was also a member of
google ai's morphnet team
where he worked on developing an
automated machine learning algorithm
based on neural network pruning jonathan
gaifman
welcome how are you doing today great
how are you
thank you for asking me i i am doing
a great thank you very much um deep
learning uh one of the things that we
mentioned right before we start here is
that this is not going to be another
ordinary episode
um there's there's some hardcore stuff
to talk about
no there's nothing to do about it we you
know you what you're doing with destiny
this idea of taking ai to the next level
you know
most people around you know don't don't
understand the the foundation of ai
and what it actually means and you're
here taking us to already to the next
level publishing papers and some of the
biggest conferences like
and new reps and uh with working with
google and machine learning
and and phd in technion so not
not nothing nothing nothing selling
short uh
and i can only imagine the complexity
that now you're bringing to the world
with desi
and so i want to cut right to the chase
jonathan how do you get
to decide that you want to dedicate your
professional career right now
to to the concept of deep learning why
deep learning
okay so so i started to look at deep
learning maybe six or seven years ago
when
it was the early days of this technology
and when thinking about deep learning
it was kind of fascinating why this
technology works how it works and when
where can we take it it was
not deployed on many applications it was
the early days
and i was wondering what we can do with
this technology and what enablement
could it be
could have done to the world and i
started to research this
and during my phd i started to look
about applications of deep learning and
how can we
we make it like more applicable for real
life
and how can we uh count more on deep
learning related algorithms
in order to to involve them in mission
critical tasks in
our world like autonomous vehicles and
and in a medical diagnosis
so this was kind of the early days when
i look at these algorithms
in the in my phd in master
so when you're when you're repeating the
words deep learning
um you know a term that really is is you
know it's not ubiquitous and it
some it is some sort of a black box for
a lot of people what do you mean when
you say
deep learning so deep learning if we
look at the world of ai which is a very
general term and here with us for
maybe 50 or 60 years we can divide it
into
a machine learning which is a a
class of algorithms and deep learning is
a subset of machine learning where it's
a
a family of algorithms that
simply do the prediction task of of
inferring from
some principle learning some principle
based on on data
and being able to be deployed and apply
on this a problem and solve this problem
in a production environment based on the
data that they learned
a before and they are mainly good in
doing some prediction tasks in
in image in image in a voice and in text
so so these are kind of the application
the native applications of deep learning
like processing signal
uh nature natural signal like
images voice and text and making some
predictions
like classifications detecting objects
in images
images transcribing a
voice and stuff like this so this is
kind of what deep learning is doing
today in our life and
it's deployed on many many applications
that we can see
in our mobile phone it deployed all over
the internet in some
of the back end of the sites that we're
using like netflix
youtube facebook google search it's
everywhere and we are not also
always familiar with the fact that it
surrounded us
with in so many applications inside and
we are using deep learning every day
jonathan why go do a phd in the technion
in deep learning you have to like i'm
sure you already know this that if you
walk down the street and you and if
your shirt said that people think you're
crazy it's it's it's like
one of the hardest things you can do
like why why
like a lot of people would say why
torture yourself how do you
see you know your academia and
and you know i'm smiling also because
i'm i'm in that path as well and so
i have a feeling i know what you're
going to say but it but it is an
elephant in the room that needs to be
said
uh actually so so i didn't dive directly
into a phd i started with the master
and search for for a topic to do some
research during my master thesis
and then i i i found deep learning is
very interesting
then i i dig a little bit and found a
world war that i want to to
to to investigate and research a little
bit further and then i i continued to a
phd
uh i think that it's something that
took me into the world of deep learning
and trying to build some more
applications
doing more research and seeing how this
technology
can can make its impact i think that
this was the
strongest motivation that i had while
continuing from the master to phd and
focusing deeply on deep learning
and so you're finishing the phd and
a lot of people with that have um you
know ai expertise or
or any ability to create meaningful
products they think okay how can i
actually use ai to
to you know to augment you know
something in our daily life whether it's
autonomous vehicles it's
and you know image recognition single
processing audio whatever
you're saying i'm not gonna deal with
one specific thing i'm going to
talk about ai in general what does that
mean to you
so we saw the situation with this
technology
those days like 2019 and we saw that
many people are trying to use deep
learning
but it's not it wasn't easier on those
days also now it's not so easy
and the the proficiency that was needed
from the developers in order to adopt
this technology into
into applications in real life in the
industry
was very high and we thought okay how
can we reduce that barrier how can we
make deep learning
simple to build simple to use simple to
deploy
and that this was kind of the motivation
i didn't want to focus on one specific
new application and
kind of collect the data and do all the
job and there one is interesting thing
in the horizontal ai approach that you
see
many many applications and many many
tasks and it's very diverse you we are
working with customers in
health care and we are working with
customers in image editing and
smart cities in and many many
applications and we kind of exposed to
to all the impact that this technology
can do to the world
and i think that this is more
interesting for for my personal
perspective than focusing on one narrow
application building it along the way
and so this was kind of the motivation
like making this
technology available for everyone for
any application
and seeing its impact uh on on all the
widths
of the available applications of that
technology
so you know now how many people are
currently working at desi
so at this we have 26 people at the
moment we are
expanding very fast yeah we started one
and a half years ago like maybe one year
ago we were only six
and then we had wow from the a
market size side walking with many many
customers at the moment so we expanded
very fast
and it was very interesting like this
stage of the startup
coming from zero to one and from six to
26 in one year it's
fascinating because you want to wow
something with a unique culture
we say you want to control everything
you want to hire
a good and a
like building company at these stages is
very fascinating in my perspective like
scaling up and the team building the
right team to the right
mission with the right product is is
very challenging
and you have to control all the details
at this stage
and so yes it's it is great
so building a culture and a lot of the
times we hear
you know about about the mission and the
vision of the company and and
and you know the ceo's responsibility to
make sure that everybody's aligned on
this vision and
you know a lot of engineers and
researchers are looking for meaning in
their work
how do you explain to your team members
the meaning of the work that you're
doing because it is a little bit more
theoretical
and less tangible than you know somebody
who's
working on security cameras for an
elderly home care
right which obviously has an immediate
impact so how do you go about explaining
that
actually we are we are seeing ourselves
as ai enablers
so in some sense we have large customers
with some let's say mobile apps that are
deployed all across the world and they
can
and they can use these applications and
see desi model like the engine behind
the the largest
applications and for the largest
companies are driven by deci technology
so being able to see your technology
working
with the largest companies applications
is is
is amazing in the sense that you feel
that you build something
that is deployed all over the world
making impact giving some value
product value for for users
and it's more than like building a
startup that will have 10
100 customers they deployed all across
the world with
applications of the largest tech
companies in the world
so this is kind of the the largest scale
that you can think that the small
startup from israel
can build technology right and so
going back to the world of deep learning
a little bit share with me a little
you know your two cents on on where
where we're headed
both where desi is headed but also as an
industry
where is the where is the deep
technology or deep learning industry
headed
in your perspective
so i think that
one of the things that we see that deep
learning will
dominate all the machine learning space
and all the ai space so if i mention at
the beginning that
at the moment deep learning is mostly
working on computer vision
on audio and nlp on text analysis
and we'll see in the future that it will
completely replace all the traditional
algorithms what is called classical
machine learning
and that is doing some medical diagnosis
that is doing some
and mathematical or statistical analysis
and so deep learning will will be the
entire ai stack in my perspective in the
future
also we are seeing a kind of
standardization of
how companies and people are building
deep learning algorithms
and we will see more and more end-to-end
tools
that help the data scientists and the
deep learning engineer to build
optimize and deploy deep learning like
what we are doing in desi so at the
moment
the the the ai market or the industry of
ai
is very fragmented with a lot of tools
that every tool is doing something very
very small
and very very unique and i think that
this market will go to platforms that
are
giving end-to-end value i think that the
first company that identified that
and tried to build it is aws with the
sage maker platform
but we'll see more and more companies
also google announced like
like last week something that they call
vertex ai which is a
end-to-end platform for ai so we'll see
companies that are building end-to-end
platform
that help from the development side even
with the data are labeling the data
and to the production side and this is
also the goal of desi like being the
the go to platform and end-to-end
platform and for deep learning
that what interesting is this is that
how we build the models
which is based on the autonomic
technology which automatically
designed the models and to get a best
performance in production okay
what does that mean what is it that you
just said
automatic neural architecture
construction this means
that if the in the past data scientist
was needed to to craft the neural
architectures
manually neural architecture is the core
of the
of the deep learning model like the
structure of the model and in the past a
data scientist was needed to craft this
manually like connect some layers
together think about the new
architectures or get something from
github
that already published in academic paper
this was non-optimal in the sense that
it was this was not tailored for the
specific task that this
um data scientist is trying to solve and
with autonac
it's an algorithm that automatically
design the structure of the deep
learning model
in order to kind of solve an
optimization problem of getting the best
accuracy
while also getting the maximal
performance in production
as we know deep learning requires huge
amount of computational
uh effort during training and also in
the production side
and in order to reduce that we are
building uh
algorithms with autonomic that are more
efficient than the common deep learning
algorithms that are available
in academic paper or in github
right and so what it sounds to me and
correct me from wrong is that
essentially you're taking the research
that you've been doing and that you love
doing and that you're fascinated by and
you turn it into just a very very
profitable business but really
you're continuing to do research on a
daily basis right
yes so one of the interesting thing is
that about one third of the company is a
research team
we are constantly doing research in the
state of the art of deep learning like
an
academic institute on one side and it's
very fun and and seeing new results and
being
like on the state of the art of the
academic papers and
and results and on the other side we try
to productize it
and give it to the world and make it
like uh
easy to use and being able to build deep
learning models automatically
very simple in very simple way so this
is kind of
a one on one end is the research on the
other hand is the product to productize
this technology
and this short route form a research
idea to to product in production that
serves customers
it's a very very very exciting
so within this past year you grew from
six to 26 you've gained a bunch of
customers you've
you've essentially you validated
everything you wanted to
to validate and where where where is
desi going from here so if as
you know the leader of this ship where
where is desi going to be either you
know you decide in one year maybe five
years
yeah so so in the short term we started
very narrow with a very
focused value proposition from the
performance side from computer vision
from edge to cloud now we are expanding
to to walk all across the domains of
deep learning from
a computer vision to nlp to audio so
this is immediate like
next quarter where we are onboarding
customers in nlp
in the longer future we see the dc as
the go to for deep learning development
so
if you need to build a deep learning
algorithms you better do it with desi
because this will give you the best
results that that's my vision
very i i have to say that i just love
that vision
and i think that one of the things that
you know we we can also touch on here is
just this idea of how big this market is
growing
it is exploding it is growing um
at such an incred an amazing rate where
you have comp
every basically every company now needs
to
leverage this technology because this
has become the staple
or the basis for or foundation for
anything it's no longer just heuristics
or just you know it now this is the
basis of understanding customers
understanding you know
products understanding performance and
optimization right so and i'm guessing
that you're
where you're sitting you're really
seeing it where all of a sudden you have
all these companies that maybe even five
years ago even two years ago
didn't have anything right yeah so so
now we are working with the experts we
are helping tech companies
to leverage this technology technology
further in the future we we are looking
also to help like the companies
that want to enter into the eye with our
platforms
so this is kind of lowering the barrier
lowering the bow of entering into ai is
one of our long-term goals
right i i love this conversation thank
you i have three questions but they're
about yonatan not about
desti or deep learning are you ready for
them i hope i'm ready
we'll start with your favorite subject
from middle school or high school
um i think it mathematics uh
i don't know it was something that was
interesting
i was good at that and i liked it
amazing who would be one of your role
models
somebody that inspires you in some way
i will say too larry and sergey from
google
i think that they built an amazing
company and it's
very interesting to to learn about the
their
their journey from the phd it's time for
do to building google
like i think that they're the role model
for me like
seeing google now uh and looking what is
google become
and thinking about the early days that's
for me the the great example of building
large company what are three words that
you would use to describe
yourself or if i were to ask anybody who
is jonathan gaifman
family desi
life i love it
thank you i can't wait to start to
understand
how your uh you know the work that
you're doing is going to implicate the
world in such a dramatic way
and i think that one of the things that
i'm excited to think about is
you know it's no matter how much you'll
know you won't even know
how far down the the snowball effect
this made
and the butterfly effect both effects
are in place here jonathan
thank you very very much stay safe and
still bye